Sonic the Hedgehog is one of Gaming's
biggest mascots the Speedy blue Hedgehog
has appeared on serial merchandise
multiple children's cartoons feature
films the Smash Brothers roster starting
countless games and a whole lot of fan
art my eyes have seen
and while Sonic was busy capturing the
hearts of countless children around the
world
he was also busy saving Sega of America
this is the story of how Sonic the
Hedgehog saved Sega
[Music]
before Sonic the Hedgehog and the Sega
Genesis there was the Sega Master System
[Music]
and before the Sega Master System
there's the sg-1000 you see before Sega
was known for making game consoles they
were creators of arcade games and slot
machines before that but we don't have
to go into the entire history I just
found that bit interesting arcades in
general were on the decline and Sega was
seriously hurting from it so when Sega
switched to creating their sg-1000 which
was absolutely stopped by the famicom
release the same year engineer Hideki
Sato said they got stars in their eyes
by the possibilities their arcade sales
have been around 5000 units per arcade
machine but the sg-1000 sold 160
000 units in its first year what could
the future hold the second master system
it was the Sega Master System it did uh
okay I guess once again it was
absolutely stopped by Nintendo whose
mascot Mario was now repeatedly jumping
on sega's dreams so it was time to Fight
Fire with Fire Sega needed a mascot of
its own and someone who could exude this
same charm as Mario and sell its castles
it needed Alex Kidd
Alex Kidd basically took Mario and tried
to change it in super minor ways instead
of jumping he punched on a controller
the jump and action buttons were swapped
literally just to be different and the
bosses were rock paper scissors matches
where you could randomly lose and have
to start over the epitome of skill
Alex Kidd did well enough and did win
over some fans but it wasn't strong
enough to move castles and the Master
System once again failed except for
weirdly in Brazil which is a super
interesting story of its own the
important thing to note about selling
consoles is you have a major upfront
cost in developing and Manufacturing
them so you kind of need them to sell in
order to recoup your costs so 1983 the
sg-1000 failed to compete with Nintendo
1984 the sg-1002 failed to compete 1985
the Mark III failed to compete and 1987
the rebranded Sega Master System failed
to compete so in 1988 why not try again
what could possibly go wrong so 1988 saw
the Japanese release of the second Mega
Drive or Sega Genesis which was released
to other regions in 1990 while the Mega
Drive did all right in 1988 as it was
the first console to harness 16-bit
Graphics it was released one week after
Super Mario Brothers 3 which well
absolutely eclipsed it damn it
damn it always my Mario I hate that guy
and while the Mega Drive initially sold
all right in Japan with 400 000 units in
this first year its success quickly
tapered off meanwhile in the west the
Genesis was released in 1990 and Sega of
America's CEO Michael Katz was tasked
with selling 1 million units in the
Castle's first year he failed I mean to
be fair he sold around 400 000 or so
units so I think he did pretty good
considering the Chokehold Nintendo and
Mario had on the world but it still
wasn't good enough for Sega so it was
time for a two-part plan number one
replace Michael Cass in North America
with Tom kalinski who would take over a
CEO which we'll get into later number
two that whole Alex kid thing didn't
work well enough we need to beat
Mario god I really hate that guy with
this red hat and mustache and overalls
and the Charming way that he goes Wahoo
and is like amazing gameplay mechanics
and the way that Mario 3 just then
second president Hayao Nakayama and the
creator of Alex Kidd kotaro hayashita
set up a contest within the company to
create a mascot who could finally
compete with Mario and it just happened
to coincide with another project two
employees were working on together one
was Yuji Naka he had been programming
games for Sega since the sg-1000 and
even programmed Fantasy Star for the
second master system for his latest game
he decided to make a sped up Ghouls and
ghosts and he was working together with
artist na uto Oshima because the game
was about speed Naruto Oshima came up
with the perfect character concept and
one we all know and love today a rabbit
I mean it makes sense right rabbits are
known for being quick while the Rabbit
part was obviously canned some of the
initial Concepts using the rabbit can
actually be seen in the future Sega Game
Rye star anyways the rabbit would pick
up and throw things but the team decided
to make the gameplay more simplistic
they thought of a bear who could curl up
and roll and when they decide the
character should be Invincible while
rolling a hedgehog kinda made sense and
anyways not the Oshima had a super sick
concept drawing of a hedgehog codenamed
Mr needle Mouse so they went with that
by April 1990 they finished a prototype
for Sonic and were given the go-ahead to
work on the project and given a full
team to help out with hirokazu yasu Hara
being a lead designer on the game who
I'm just calling out here as I think
he's actually an unsung hero of the
Sonic series while Alex Kidd had
initially minor differences to
differentiate him from Mario Sonic was
shaping up to be very unique and its own
special thing but that was Japan let's
go to America
[Music]
Tom kalinski had taken over a Sega of
America and immediately told sake of
Japan they were a bunch of marketing
losers not really but when translating
it to my interpretation pissed off the
board of directors and with only sega's
President Hayao nakayama's blessing in
Japan completely changed everything
about how the Genesis was marketed in
the West on the Sonic front Michael Katz
the previous CEO has seen the original
concept art for Mr needle Mouse and
hated it he hated it so much that he
basically told Sega of Japan there was
zero chance the game would sell in the
west but Tom Kolinski took one look at
the Sonic art and said
what is this in particular he wasn't a
fan of Sonic's fangs the rock band or
his human girlfriend Madonna So he and
the American product manager Madeline
Schroeder came back with a number of
changes to soften Sonic up for the west
and according to Madeleine Schroeder we
softened him up and it was war but
amazingly after stiff disagreements and
resentment Sega of Japan finally agreed
to change Sonic's look and despite the
American team's misgivings about Sonic's
look when they saw the actual gameplay
later that year they were absolutely
Blown Away by it and thought they had a
massive winner on their hands and that
might be where the story ends but Sega
was against Nintendo who at the time had
a complete Stranglehold on the market
and that's where it was genuinely going
to take some smart marketing Acumen to
get Sega Genesis and Sonic in the hands
of consumers so Tom kalinski presented
his crazy ideas to sega's board of
directors in Japan I'm gonna cut the
price of the Genesis by 50 so we sell it
at a loss
also I know it's disrespectful in Japan
to be rude to the competition but you
know what guys all our ad money is going
towards telling Nintendo they can suck
it
also you know that weird Mario Hedgehog
game you guys are putting all your money
into yeah I'm gonna bundle with the Sega
Genesis so it's free
oh and uh by the way Alex cute is made
it best
unsurprisingly this invoked the absolute
furry of the board of directors and
amazingly even though the entire board
of directors hated him then and there
hayan Nakayama told him to go ahead with
it as he'd hired Tom to shake things up
so summer 1991 at CES in Chicago Tom
kalinsky and Sega of America began to
reveal Sonic to Consumers their Booth
featured a cheeky side-by-side of Super
Mario World and Sonic the Hedgehog to
show off what they thought was clearly
the better game
or Sonic whatever meanwhile they set up
play tests around the country for kids
to compare Sonic and the not yet
released in the states Super Mario World
where they found 80 percent preferred
Sonic not a bad way to Market your game
so with that information in mind and the
fact that Tom kalinski and Sega America
were genuinely worried that if Sonic
failed Sega would fail along with it
especially with the looming release of
the Super Nintendo of August 23 1991
Sega got to work Sonic would be
releasing sometime that summer so gotta
go fast the idea was to make Sega look
like the cool version of Nintendo and of
course Sonic would be a major selling
point for that they partnered with LA's
KISS FM for a 16 weeks of Summer where
they promoted Sega and did consistent
giveaways next they approached major
gaming magazines like egm video games
and Computer Entertainment and Game Pro
obtaining cover features on those
magazines for Sonic and eventually even
releasing a Sonic comic next as money
was tight instead of running a TV ad
campaign on major networks Sega finance
a prime time special shot at Universal
Studios featuring various teenage sitcom
Stars competing in challenges like
Hedgehog races which would be called
Sega star kids challenge then there is
the lingering fact that kalinsky wanted
Sonic to be a packing game for the Sega
Genesis but they still had 150
000 unsold systems with Altered Beasts
attached in their warehouses and
something like a hundred thousand units
just sitting on store shelves so you
know what that madman did give everyone
who buys a Genesis a mail-in coupon for
Sonic for free two free games nobody
pays for Sonic in my house and finally
on June 23 1991 Sonic the Hedgehog began
to hit store shelves and here's the
thing about Sonic I failed to mention
oh it good
[Music]
and between all of this marketing and
promotion as well as Word of Mouth of
just how great of a game Sonic was
Genesis sales started to slowly ramp up
to the point that they were starting to
quadruple meanwhile Kolinski had been
pushing to get Genesis sold in Walmart
for pretty much his entire tenure and by
the end of summer they finally budged
and had added the console to stores in
other words suddenly the Sega Genesis
went from being a kinda Meandering
mediocre story to a staggering success
we're talking the CEO of SEC of America
genuinely worried the company would
collapse if this failed here's a crazy
fact Sonic even outsold Super Mario
World for a time in North America not
only that but the Genesis actually
outsold the Super Nintendo during the
holiday season of 1991. by the end of
1991 Sonic had sold over 1 million
copies and it was Blockbuster's highest
rented game of the year thanks to Sonic
and the sales Acumen of Sega of America
the Sega Genesis went Toe to Toe with
the Super Nintendo in America during
their entire runs great console war are
and if you don't think Sega of America
or their marketing mattered here's the
thing in Japan the mega drive wasn't
even the second highest selling console
it was in third place far behind both
the super famicom and the PC engine
known as the turbo Graphics 16 in the
states Yes you heard that right the
turbo Graphics 16 a console I'm willing
to bet many of you have never heard of
sold better than the Sega Genesis in
Japan either way none of it would have
been possible if it weren't for a
certain blue Hedgehog Sonic would end up
having an entire run of Mega successful
games in the west with Sonic 2 and my
personal favorite Sonic 3 and its tie in
Sonic and Knuckles all releasing in
quick succession Sonic spin-off games
like the Sonic spinball also proved
successful for Sega and Sonic became a
mascot who would help sell their future
systems today while Sega eventually fell
off of the console wars during the
Dreamcast era in part due to
overspending on a certain game
Sonic is still one of Gaming's most
beloved characters even having one of
the first critical and commercially
successful video game film adaptations
which of course Mario had to copy and be
even more successful with his movie
[Music]
thanks Mario you unclogged Sonic's
moment while it's important to remember
that Tom kalinski helped market and sell
Sonic in the west ultimately Sonic was a
cultural phenomenon in his own right the
game resonated with players in a way
that few others ever have and in spite
of the American Marketing team's
misgivings about Sonic's look his Art
and Design were definitely a huge part
of his success with his cute but also
super cool aesthetic and that's how this
Plucky guy would save an entire company
and give it legs for years to come I
hope you enjoyed and if you did make
sure to check out next week's episode on
one of my favorite franchises The Legend
of Zelda and if you missed it last week
I cover Resident Evil 4 and it was a
total Banger so check that out